نعم غنوه يعني بالفعل هذه الليله تشهد
اقتحامات موسعه في محافظات ومدن متعدده في
الضفه الغربيه الابرز والاهم هو استشهاد
مواطن في بلده بيت ريما قضاء رام الله حيث
داهمت قوات الاحتلال بيت ريما
وانتشرت في اماكن ومناطق متفرقه من البلده
اندلعت مواجهات بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال
اسفرت كما ذكرنا عن استشهاد مواطن وصل الى
مستشفى س فيتا الحكومي كما كان هناك بحسب
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطين حوالي ست اصابات
برصاص الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها ل بلده بيت
ريما طبعا باستشهاد المواطن هذه الليله
نتحدث عن سبع شهداء منذ بدايه هذا العام
في الضفه الغربيه وارتفع عدد الشهداء منذ
السابع من اكتوبر في الضفه الغربيه الى
326 شهيدا باستشهاد المواطن في مريما هذه
الليله في هذه اللحظات ايضا قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم مخيم بلاطه والمنطقه الشرقيه في
مدينه نابلس كانت اقتحمت المخيم والمنطقه
الشرقيه من بوابه بيت فوريك جنوب المدينه
رافق هذه القوه التي اقتحمت مخيم بلاطه
جرافه اسرائيليه واندلعت اشتباكات لا تزال
تدور حتى هذه اللحظه في حاره الحشاشين في
مخيم بلاطه والحديث عن عدد من الاصابات في
مخيم بلاطه لم يتمكن حتى اللحظه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني من الوصول الى المصابين
ولا زال الاقتحام مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه في
مخيم بلاطه وسط اندلاع لاشتباكات مسلحه
بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
التي اقتحمت بلاطه في نابلس شمال الضفه
الغربيه في الشمال نبقى في قلقيليه تحديدا
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال قريه عزون قضاء
قلقيليه وداهمت وفتشت عدد من منازل
المواطنين كما اقتحمت مناطق متفرقه في
محافظه الخليل جنوب الضفه الغربيه لازال
الاقتحام حتى اللحظه مستمر لمدينه دوه
جنوب الخليل تقتحم احد منازل المواطنين
منذ حوالي ساعه وتقوم بتفتيش المنزل
تفتيشا دقيقا شهود عيان قريبين من المنزل
تحدثوا عن سماع اصوات خراب ودمار كبير لحق
بهذا المنزل الذي يتم تفتيشه حتى هذه
اللحظه كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال مدينه
يطا جنوب الخليل من بوابه زيف وداهمت عدد
من منازل المواطنين فتشت وخلفت ايضا خرابا
كبيرا في هذه المنازل كما اقتحمت حلحول
شمال الضفه شمال مدينه الخليل وداهمت عدد
من المنازل رفقتها شاحنه ثقيله والاقتحام
في حلحول كان لاحد المطابع في المدينه وسط
اندلاع مواجهات ايضا بين الشبان وقوات
الاحتلال في حلحول شمال مدينه الخليل
بمعنى ان هذه الليله تشهد اقتحامات مستمره
متواصله الابرز والاهم كما ذكرنا مخيم
بلاطه في نابلس شمال الضفه الغربيه بيت
ريما حديث عن شهيد وعدد من الاصابات
قلقيليه والخليل كذلك جنوب الضفه الغربيه
التي لا تزال حتى اللحظه تشهد اقتحامات
مستمره ومتواصله